Witaj ponownie w Quantum Computing in Practice. To jest odcinek 6. Dzisiaj skupimy się na jednej z moich ulubionych
zastosowań komputerów kwantowych — symulowaniu natury. W tym odcinku omówimy kroki wymagane
do przeprowadzenia tego dla dowolnego problemu dynamiki kwantowej, czyli problemu znalezienia, jak opis
układu kwantowego zmienia się w czasie. Zrobimy to najpierw na wysokim poziomie, a następnie przyjrzymy się konkretnemu przykładowi i przejdziemy
przez niego szczegółowo — mianowicie eksperymentowi IBM z 2023 roku, który zademonstrował użyteczność kwantową. Dla szybkiej motywacji na
początku: jedna z najbardziej znanych historii, którą my z dziedziny informatyki kwantowej opowiadamy wciąż od nowa,
to historia Richarda Feynmana wygłaszającego wykład w Caltech w 1959 roku, który w zasadzie
dostarczył motywacji dla całej dziedziny na dziesięciolecia. Przemówienie nosiło tytuł „There's Plenty of Room at the
Bottom" — zabawny tytuł, ale podstawowa idea była taka, że twierdził, że wciąż jest tyle bogatej fizyki do
odkrycia na poziomie mikroskopowym.
Ten konkretny wykład nie cieszył się dużym zainteresowaniem aż do lat 80., kiedy technologia znacznie się rozwinęła. Feynman
doprecyzował i rozwinął swoje przesłanie z czasem. Wrócił do Caltech w latach 80. i wygłosił inną pracę zatytułowaną
„Simulating Nature with Computers", w której wyraźnie powiedział, że chce mówić o możliwości istnienia
dokładnej symulacji, w której komputer robi dokładnie to samo co natura.
W zasadzie chodzi o możliwość pozbycia się prymitywnych przybliżeń tego, co dzieje się na poziomie atomowym i zastąpienia ich
komputerami, które rozumieją i wykorzystują fizykę kwantową, nie tylko symulując to, co robi natura, ale emulując ją.
Przypomnij sobie tę oś czasu, którą pokazałem w poprzednim odcinku. Na jednym końcu mieliśmy problemy łatwe do
rozwiązania, które nie będą wymagać żadnego przyspieszenia, jakie może zaoferować komputer kwantowy. Ale na drugim końcu mamy problemy
bardzo trudne, wymagające odpornych na błędy maszyn kwantowych, których jeszcze nie mamy.
Na szczęście wierzymy, że istnieje sporo problemów symulacyjnych leżących tu pośrodku, czyli w obszarze, w którym
możemy teraz pracować. I jest wiele powodów, by być podekscytowanym i zaintrygowanym tą perspektywą, ponieważ
symulacja natury jest podstawą wielu ekscytujących obszarów zastosowań. Tylko wymienię kilka. Gdybyśmy mogli lepiej
symulować naturę, moglibyśmy przyspieszyć odkrywanie nowych materiałów, tworzyć lepsze leki i medycynę, lub
nawet eksplorować nową fizykę leżącą u podstaw fizyki cząstek elementarnych lub kosmologii. Ale zanim ty, ja lub ktokolwiek spróbuje
zastosować informatykę kwantową w tych ekscytujących obszarach, na razie będzie trzeba zrozumieć podstawowe kroki
typowego przepływu pracy opartego na symulacji.
Najpierw będziesz chciał/a zidentyfikować kwantowy układ będący przedmiotem zainteresowania. To poinformuje cię o Hamiltonianie rządzącym jego ewolucją
czasową i znaczącym opisie jego właściwości początkowych, czyli jego stanu.
Następnie będziesz potrzebować odpowiedniej metody implementacji ewolucji czasowej tego stanu. Mając te składniki
posortowane, kolejne kroki obejmują przeprowadzenie właściwego eksperymentu.
Generalnie wiążą się one z optymalizacją implementacji circuit algorytmu ewolucji czasowej, wykonaniem
circuit lub circuits na sprzęcie kwantowym oraz przetwarzaniem końcowym wyników. Możemy zatem
wymienić podstawowe kroki eksperymentu symulacyjnego w następujący sposób.
Identyfikacja Hamiltonianu układu, kodowanie Hamiltonianu, przygotowanie stanu, ewolucja stanu,
optymalizacja circuit, wykonanie circuit i przetwarzanie końcowe.
Ale to dość szczegółowe kroki. Pamiętaj, że cztery etapy frameworku Qiskit patterns, który pomaga
nam zrozumieć, jak zaimplementować procedurę w Qiskit, to: mapowanie, optymalizacja circuit, wykonanie circuit i
przetwarzanie końcowe. Tak więc te cztery pierwsze kroki są w rzeczywistości objęte parasolem mapowania i właśnie dlatego
poświęciliśmy cały odcinek temu pierwszemu etapowi — jeśli go przegapiłeś/aś, wróć i obejrzyj poprzedni odcinek.
Teraz najpierw przejdźmy przez to, co te kroki w ogóle oznaczają, zanim zagłębimy się w jakikolwiek kod. Pierwszą podstawową rzeczą, którą musimy
zrobić, aby przeprowadzić eksperyment symulacyjny, jest identyfikacja Hamiltonianu opisującego układ. Czasami —
właściwie często — są one dobrze znane, innym razem musimy je zestawiać z rozumienia wkładów energetycznych
małych podzbiorów pełnego układu, jak tutaj, gdzie hi jest Hamiltonianem działającym na jeden z n podukładów h.
Będziemy też musieli zauważyć, czy układ składa się z fermionów czy bozonów, jeśli mamy do czynienia z cząstkami elementarnymi. Następnie
musimy zakodować Hamiltonian i przetłumaczyć go na wyrażenia zrozumiałe dla komputerów kwantowych. Często
te Hamiltoniany będą zbudowane z cząstek elementarnych lub układów spinowych. Jeśli symulujemy fermiony lub bozony,
będziemy musieli wybrać transformację kodowania, jak Jordan-Wigner lub Bravyi-Kitaev. Te transformacje
powiedzą nam, jak przetłumaczyć definicję Hamiltonianu zapisaną w kategoriach oryginalnych składowych — fermionów lub
bozonów — na operatory Pauliego, które są łatwo przekształcalne w gate'y na komputerze kwantowym. Na przykład transformacja Jordan-Wigner
zdefiniowana tutaj daje odwzorowanie operatorów fermionowych na operatory Pauliego. Jeśli mamy już do czynienia
z układami spinowymi o spinie 1/2, które są bardzo powszechne, to jesteśmy gotowi, abstrahując od ewentualnych współczynników normalizacyjnych,
i nie musimy używać żadnego schematu kodowania. Po zakodowaniu żądanego Hamiltonianu w zestawie gate'ów komputera kwantowego,
kluczowym kolejnym krokiem jest określenie odpowiedniego początkowego stanu kwantowego, od którego zacznie się nasza
symulacja. Ten stan powinien idealnie odzwierciedlać pewne fizyczne znaczenie lub konfigurację
badanego układu. Na przykład, jeśli interesuje nas eksploracja energii stanu podstawowego cząsteczki, moglibyśmy
zacząć od przybliżenia Hartree-Focka lub innego łatwo przygotowywanego stanu, który ma znaczące pokrycie z prawdziwym
stanem podstawowym. Wybór początkowego stanu podstawowego wpływa nie tylko na zbieżność algorytmów wariacyjnych,
takich jak VQE, wariacyjny solwer kwantowy, ale także na dokładność i wydajność
ewolucji czasowej lub próbkowania w kwantowym szacowaniu faz. W istocie stan początkowy służy jako
punkt startowy dla obliczeń, przygotowując grunt do wyodrębnienia użytecznych obserwabli dotyczących układu kwantowego,
który modelujemy. Przygotowanie dowolnego stanu n-qubitowego, gdzie ci są stanami bazy obliczeniowej, a ai jest
współczynnikiem każdego stanu i warunkiem normalizacji 2 do n minus jeden, można ogólnie podejść przez
zainicjalizowanie stanu operatorem o, gdzie stanem startowym byłby standardowy stan bazowy samych zer, często zapisywany
tak dla uproszczenia. Ogólnie wymaga to wykładniczej liczby bramek C-NOT. Często
interesuje nas konkretny stan początkowy układu i jego przygotowanie można zaimplementować przy rozsądnej liczbie
zasobów. Stany produktowe, na przykład, w których qubity nie są ze sobą splątane, wymagają tylko jednoqUbitowych
operacji. Nie mieliśmy jeszcze okazji rozmawiać o troteryzacji,
choć niektórzy z was pewnie już ją znają. W istocie troteryzacja jest metodą obliczania eksponentacji macierzy,
która używa przybliżeń do radzenia sobie z wykładniczą naturą nieprzemiennych operatorów. Gdy dwa operatory, jak HA
i HB, nie przemienią, musimy zastosować sprytny trik i naprzemiennie stosować odpowiednie eksponenty
e^(-i*HA) i e^(-i*HB) przez n razy.
Operatory ewolucji są stosowane naprzemiennie. Nie będę tu przytaczać dowodu, ale udostępnię link
do prostego dowodu tego stwierdzenia w opisie. Ale główny wniosek jest taki. Ewolucja czasowa jest
ważną częścią mapowania. Troteryzacja rozkłada ciągłą interakcję na dyskretne kroki, które mogą
być zaimplementowane na komputerze kwantowym. Po wygenerowaniu strotteryzowanego circuit skończyliśmy
etap mapowania. Możemy teraz przejść do optymalizacji circuit.
Aby to zrobić, oto co musi zostać osiągnięte. Musi istnieć układ qubitów odwzorowujący wirtualne qubity
twojego circuit na fizyczne qubity sprzętu. Jest to potrzebne, ponieważ sprzęt może mieć określone topologie,
które ograniczają bezpośrednią interakcję fizycznych qubitów. Podczas gdy implementacja
circuit kwantowego często zakłada możliwość interakcji dowolnego qubitu z dowolnym innym qubitem. Następnie musimy wstawiać
bramki SWAP w razie potrzeby, aby kierować interakcje między qubitami, które nie są połączone. Musimy przetłumaczyć
bramki w naszym circuit na instrukcje architektury zestawu instrukcji (ISA), które
mogą być bezpośrednio wykonywane na sprzęcie. Następnie musimy przeprowadzić optymalizacje circuit, aby zminimalizować
głębokość circuit i liczbę bramek. Ten krok można też wykonać na wirtualnym circuit — circuit, w którym qubity
nie zostały jeszcze odwzorowane na topologię urządzenia. Ale pamiętaj, że wiele z tego jest robione automatycznie za ciebie w
Qiskit. Zobaczymy dokładnie jak w następnej części tego wykładu. Po etapie optymalizacji jesteśmy gotowi uruchomić
circuit za pomocą prymitywu. W przypadku większości eksperymentów symulacyjnych interesuje cię zrozumienie zmian
pewnych właściwości układu w czasie. Dlatego prawdopodobnie użyjesz prymitywu estymatora, ponieważ
pozwoli ci mierzyć wartości oczekiwane obserwabli odpowiadających konkretnym właściwościom. Następnie
skonfigurujemy najlepsze opcje dla estymatora, które mogą dodawać techniki tłumienia błędów i mitygacji błędów. Na koniec uruchomimy
eksperyment. Ostatnim krokiem jest przetwarzanie końcowe wszystkich danych. Wyodrębnia ono zmierzone wartości oczekiwane lub jeśli
używasz samplera, próbkowany rozkład prawdopodobieństwa w bazie obliczeniowej. Jeśli potrzebujesz tylko
wartości oczekiwanych obserwabli zainteresowania, można je bezpośrednio uzyskać z prymitywu estymatora
zarówno w ich surowej, jak i poddanej mitygacji błędów postaci. Często następnie używa się zmierzonych wartości oczekiwanych
do innych obliczeń dla innych interesujących wielkości, które nie wymagają obliczeń kwantowych i można je
obliczyć na klasycznym komputerze.
Teraz przejdziemy przez prawdziwy przykład z bardzo wpływowej pracy, którą IBM opublikował kilka lat temu, zatytułowanej
„Evidence for Utility of Quantum Computing Before Fault Tolerance". Ta praca, którą pieszczotliwie skracamy
do „utility paper", stała się bardzo wpływową pracą w dziedzinie informatyki kwantowej niemal natychmiast po publikacji.
Ogólna teza pracy jest taka, że hałaśliwy komputer kwantowy produkował dokładne wyniki, czyli wartości oczekiwane,
używając 127 qubitów i 2880 bramek — poza możliwościami
obliczeń metodą brute force, czyli dokładnej symulacji circuit kwantowych wykonywanych przez sprzęt. Ta praca była
ważna również dlatego, że pokazała, że komputer kwantowy może być używany do weryfikacji lub porównania wyników z innymi
przybliżonymi klasycznymi metodami symulacji kwantowych, takimi jak algorytmy sieci tensorowych, gdzie rozwiązanie
nie było znane a priori. Co jest też całkiem fajne, to że teraz inni, używając systemów IBM Quantum
w chmurze i Qiskit, mogą samodzielnie powielać i weryfikować te wyniki.
Pokażę ci, jak to zrobić. Tak więc w tym przykładzie będziemy nieco bardziej konkretni co do
kroków związanych z mapowaniem tego problemu na wejścia zrozumiałe dla urządzenia kwantowego. W tym przypadku będziemy
symulować dynamikę całkowitego namagnesowania układu magnetycznych dipoli spinowych na siatce w
obecności zewnętrznego pola magnetycznego. Układ można opisać modelem Isinga z poprzecznym polem magnetycznym.
Modelujemy to za pomocą sparametryzowanego circuit kwantowego, gdzie parametry odpowiadają regulowanej wartości
interakcji spin-spin lub interakcji z oraz sile pola magnetycznego X. Teraz
ta seria nosi tytuł „Quantum Computing in Practice". Dlatego omówimy też procedury w tym eksperymencie,
które wdrożymy, aby wyniki były jak najlepsze. Następnie omówimy sposób usuwania
złych qubitów lub qubitów o niskiej wierności bramek lub czasach dekoherencji, które mogłyby drastycznie wpłynąć na
wyniki eksperymentu. Te złe qubity mogą powstawać z powodu słabej wcześniejszej kalibracji
lub układów dwupoziomowych oddziałujących z qubitem. Usunięcie niektórych qubitów z natywnej topologii sprzętu odpowiada
rozważeniu układu na siatce opisanej przez wynikową topologię. Omówimy też tworzenie
sparametryzowanego circuit kwantowego, który implementuje ewolucję czasową układu za pomocą troteryzacji.
W tym celu ważne będzie zidentyfikowanie warstw splątujących, które są kluczową częścią głównej
techniki mitygacji błędów, którą zastosujemy później. Chcę się upewnić, że ty jako widz/widzka wiesz,
że możesz śledzić wszystko, o czym zaraz będę mówić, w tutorialu podlinkowanym poniżej i na platformie IBM
Quantum Learning Platform. W tym tutorialu możesz zauważyć, że stworzyliśmy serię funkcji pomocniczych
wcześnie w notatniku, na które możemy powoływać się później, aby ułatwić sobie życie. Chcę o nich wspomnieć
nie dlatego, że jest to część oficjalnego lub formalnego procesu, ale dlatego, że eksperymentatorzy często tak robią
w prawdziwym życiu, aby pomagać sobie w prowadzeniu tych typów eksperymentów. Pokazuje nam też, jak zamierzamy podzielić nasz
problem jeszcze bardziej. Funkcje, które definiujemy w notatniku, są następujące. Usuwanie sprzężeń qubitów.
Definiowanie sprzężeń qubitów. Konstruowanie sprzężeń warstw. Konstruowanie warstw splątujących. I na koniec definiowanie
strotteryzowanego circuit. Następnie porozmawiajmy o sprzężeniach warstw, które pomagają definiować, jak qubity
oddziałują ze swoimi sąsiadami podczas symulacji. Nasze urządzenia kwantowe używają czegoś zwanego układem
„heavy hexagonal". To specjalny wzorzec łączenia qubitów. W tym układzie możemy pogrupować połączenia zwane krawędziami w trzy
oddzielne zestawy, gdzie żadne dwa połączenia w tym samym zestawie nie współdzielą qubitu. Jest to
ważne, ponieważ na prawdziwym komputerze kwantowym nie możemy uruchamiać dwuqubitowych bramek w tym samym czasie, jeśli angażują one ten
sam qubit. Każdy qubit może być zaangażowany tylko w jedną bramkę na raz. Dzieląc
wszystkie połączenia na trzy warstwy, możemy zastosować dwuqubitowe bramki na całym urządzeniu w trzech
rundach, upewniając się, że żaden qubit nie jest używany w więcej niż jednej bramce na warstwę. Te
bramki implementują interakcję ZZ z modelu Isinga i są powtarzane w każdym kroku symulacji zwanym
krokiem Trottera. Twirling modyfikuje szum w urządzeniu, tak że nawet prosty model szumu
ma szansę być dokładny. Umożliwia to też dokładne nauczenie się modelu szumu i wykorzystanie uzyskanych
informacji w technikach mitygacji błędów.
Następnie musimy usunąć złe qubity z naszej listy możliwych fizycznych qubitów, których możemy użyć w
eksperymencie. Jak mówiłem, qubit może stać się zły z różnych powodów. Czasem to po prostu zła
kalibracja — prosty błąd, który można naprawić przez ponowną kalibrację.
Czasem jest to trochę bardziej skomplikowane i związane z czymś, co nazywamy TLS — dwupoziomowym defektem interfejsowym,
który prowadzi do fluktuacji parametrów qubitu i relaksacji. Można to
rozwiązać przez podgrzanie całego układu i ponowne ochłodzenie. Ale to zajmuje chwilę i nie jest możliwe
przez chmurę. Więc na razie najłatwiej jest po prostu wykluczyć je z naszej listy możliwych fizycznych
qubitów, które będziemy używać. Możesz łatwo zidentyfikować, które qubity nie zachowują się zgodnie z oczekiwaniami, na platformie IBM Quantum.
Możesz tam wykreślić charakterystyki qubitów na platformie lub pobrać je jako CSV. Następnie utwórz listę wszystkich
qubitów, które chcesz wykluczyć i po prostu usuń je z listy wszystkich fizycznych qubitów urządzenia.
No dobrze. Kontynuujmy nasz etap mapowania — generowanie strotteryzowanego circuit. Jak pokazaliśmy
wcześniej, troteryzacja dyskretyzuje ewolucję czasową na serię kroków i musimy zdecydować, ile kroków.
Wybierzemy sześć. Ale ogólnie strategia polega na zbalansowaniu czegoś, co nazywamy błędem Trottera — będącego
algorytmicznym błędem aproksymacji — z błędem wynikającym z dekoherencji. Więcej kroków Trottera zmniejsza błąd aproksymacji,
ale wymaga głębszych circuit kwantowych, które doświadczają więcej szumu dekoherencji. Zdefiniujemy
circuit w kategoriach parametru theta, czyli siły zewnętrznego pola magnetycznego, sprzężeń warstw i
liczby kroków i qubitów, a oczywiście backend'u urządzenia. Ze względu na
zależność namagnesowania układu od siły zewnętrznego pola magnetycznego, interesujące jest
wykonanie symulacji przy różnych wartościach siły pola magnetycznego, które przekładają się na różne kąty RX
obrotu dla RX w circuit. Mając już wygenerowany nasz circuit, przejdziemy do jego optymalizacji.
Pierwszym krokiem jest zdefiniowanie menedżera przejść. Pamiętaj, że w kontekście Qiskit SDK transpilacja odnosi się do
procesu przekształcania wejściowego circuit w formę odpowiednią do wykonania na urządzeniu kwantowym.
Transpilacja zazwyczaj przebiega w sekwencji kroków zwanych przejściami transpilera. Menedżer przejść to obiekt, który
przechowuje listę przejść transpilera i może je wykonywać na circuit. Utwórz menedżer przejść przez zainicjalizowanie obiektu menedżera przejść
listą przejść transpilera. Na koniec nasz menedżer przejść
stworzy circuit ISA — circuit napisany w kategoriach architektury zestawu instrukcji backend'u,
opisujący circuit i bramki natywne dla backend'u, ale bez informacji o czasie potrzebnych do uruchomienia
circuit. Teraz jesteśmy gotowi do wykonania naszego circuit — to krok trzeci Qiskit patterns. Jak stwierdzono wcześniej,
z pewnością użyjemy estymatora jako naszego prymitywu z wyboru dla tego eksperymentu, ponieważ chcemy zmierzyć
całkowite namagnesowanie układu, a szacowanie wartości oczekiwanych obserwabli jest właśnie tym, do czego estymator był
zaprojektowany. W tym kroku kluczowe będzie też określenie naszych opcji mitygacji błędów. Użyjemy ekstrapolacji
do zera szumu, aby uzyskać jak najlepsze wyniki. W szczególności w tutorialu zobaczysz, że określamy dwie lub więcej
wartości współczynnika szumu, dla których oceniamy modele ekstrapolowane, i określamy
probabilistyczne wzmocnienie błędów jako opcję wzmocnienia. Probabilistyczne
wzmocnienie błędów, czyli PA, było naprawdę ulubioną techniką mitygacji błędów tutaj, ponieważ skaluje się znacznie
lepiej niż inne opcje. I to jest ważne, gdy pracujemy na poziomie ponad 100 qubitów.
I na koniec uruchamiamy eksperyment — zajmie to trochę czasu, ale na razie odwołajmy się do danych
umieszczonych w kolejce i zapisanych w tutorialu. Zbadamy metadane, zwracając szczególną uwagę na warstwowe bramki i
zmitigowane warstwy, ponieważ za chwilę użyjemy ich do usunięcia wielu błędów z naszych surowych danych. Prawie jesteśmy gotowi
wykreślić nasze ostateczne wyniki. Ale zanim to zrobimy, dodajmy tu krótką wstawkę o tym, co dokładnie oznacza
ekstrapolacja do zera szumu, czyli ZNE. Omówiliśmy ją krótko we wcześniejszych odcinkach, ale dla przypomnienia: ekstrapolacja
do zera szumu to technika mitygacji błędów, która usuwa efekty nieznanego szumu podczas wykonywania circuit, które można
skalować w znany sposób. Zakłada, że wartości oczekiwane skalują się z szumem przez znana funkcję pokazaną tutaj, gdzie parametry
lambda określają siłę szumu i mogą być wzmacniane. ZNE można zaimplementować wykonując następujące kroki.
Najpierw wzmocnij szum circuit dla kilku współczynników szumu: lambda 1, lambda 2,
lambda 3 i tak dalej. Uruchom każdy wzmocniony szumowo circuit, aby zmierzyć
wartość oczekiwaną a(lambda 1), a(lambda 2) i tak dalej. A następnie dokonaj ekstrapolacji z powrotem do granicy
zerowego szumu — wartości oczekiwanej a(zero).
Głównym wyzwaniem w pomyślnej implementacji ZNE jest posiadanie dokładnego modelu szumu w wartości oczekiwanej
i wzmacnianie szumu w znany sposób.
Istnieją trzy powszechne sposoby implementacji wzmocnienia błędów dla ZNE: skalowanie czasu trwania impulsów przez kalibrację,
powtarzanie bramek w cyklach tożsamości oraz dodawanie szumu przez próbkowanie kanałów Pauliego.
Tę ostatnią nazywamy PA. Probabilistyczne wzmocnienie błędów jest tu najlepszym wyborem, ponieważ rozciąganie impulsów jest bardzo
kosztowne obliczeniowo. Składanie bramek pozbawione jest gwarancji teoretycznych zachowania biasu szumu. Ale PA można
zastosować do dowolnego circuit, który można uruchomić z natywnymi współczynnikami szumu, ale wymaga nauczenia się modelu szumu. PA zakłada
ten sam warstwowy model szumu co probabilistyczne anulowanie błędów.
Jednak unika on narzutu próbkowania, który skaluje się wykładniczo z szumem circuit. Aby nauczyć się modelu szumu,
musimy najpierw zidentyfikować unikalne warstwy dwuqubitowych operacji w circuit.
Dla każdej warstwy należy wykonać twirling Pauliego dwuqubitowych bramek, aby upewnić się, że szum jest dobrze opisany przez model szumu tłumienia.
Powtarzaj pary tożsamościowe warstw przy różnych głębokościach i na koniec dopasuj wierność lub błąd dla każdego kanału szumu. I
oczywiście, chociaż polecam rozumienie tej metody w pewnym zakresie, robienie tego ręcznie w Qiskit jest
znacznie prostsze, co pokazano w tutorialu. Teraz spójrzmy na wykreślone dane. Przerywana
szara linia pokazuje dokładne wyniki uzyskane przybliżonymi metodami klasycznymi z błędem aproksymacji
zbieżnym do niskiego progu. Jak widać, surowe dane dla różnych wybranych przez nas współczynników szumu
są dość daleko od tej przerywanej linii. Ciągła niebieska linia pokazuje dane uwzględniające nasze przetwarzanie ZNE
i od razu widać, że jest znacznie bliżej dokładnych wyników.
Podsumowując, zaszumione wartości wykazują duże odchylenie od dokładnych wartości.
Zmitigowane wartości są bliskie dokładnym wartościom, demonstrując użyteczność techniki mitygacji opartej na PA.
I to w zasadzie kończy ten odcinek. Szybko podsumowując to, czego się nauczyliśmy: symulacja kwantowa jest jednym
z najbardziej obiecujących obszarów zastosowań w krótkim i średnim terminie.
Ma szeroki zakres zastosowań — od farmaceutyki po fizykę wysokich energii,
naukę o materiałach i nie tylko. Praca „utility paper" IBM opublikowana w 2023 roku wskazała
drogę do możliwości używania komputerów kwantowych do odkryć naukowych. Przepracowaliśmy też powiązany
tutorial towarzyszący tej pracy szczegółowo. Kroki do przepracowania problemu symulacyjnego od początku
do końca są stosunkowo proste, szczególnie gdy już się je opanuje. Mam nadzieję, że
odtąd będziesz mógł/mogła używać tego wideo i tutorialu jako przewodnika do jeszcze większej liczby problemów symulacyjnych w przyszłości.
Dziękuję za oglądanie i do zobaczenia następnym razem w Quantum Computing in Practice.